euh d'abord je vais vous montrer c'est
le 28 novembre 2018 qu'on a découvert
Louis Boyard c'était pour une spéciale
gilet jaune et dès cette première
apparition il avait voulu faire un petit
coup d'éclat et je vais vous dire ce
qu'il avait dit en coulisses après
regardez c'est vrai qu'on entend bien
s'il vous plaît passer le micro non mais
attends attends attends attends attends
s'il vous plaît attends s'il vous plaît
oui
non mais il faut parler dans le micro
faut parler dans le micro on vous
appelle ça fait un an que les lycéens se
mobilisent on parle d'invisibilisation
il y a un truc dont vous parlez pas et
sans déconner ça fait deux heures qu'on
est ici à faire les pots de fleurs moi
j'ai mis à faire de mon vendredi
que je pouvais venir pour parler des
jeunes je peux pas parler des jeunes on
est ici à temps pour faire les pots de
fleurs pendant des calmez-vous à faire
de mon vendredi c'est venu pour faire
des des des alors partez ça fait deux
heures que vous êtes là on vous on vous
écoute non mais non mais là n'importe
quoi
j'ai déjà des sorties de plateau le
Boyard c'est sa spécialité et il vient
sur un plateau pour en partir euh voilà
et vous savez ce qu'il avait dit
après ce passage il avait expliqué à la
prod qu'il était très content de la
séquence et que ceci voulait faire donc
déjà voilà il avait fait son petit coup
d'éclat
on l'avait bien aimé parce que j'ai dit
tiens il y a une personnalité il y a un
petit truc il y a une moustache
saillante j'aime bien on a voulu
réinviter en tant que chroniqueur et en
faire un chroniqueur sa première en tant
que chroniqueur c'était le 30 août 2021
et pendant de nombreuses émissions il
était vraiment heureux d'être là
et les deux on dirait les deux frères
ça va Louis ça va oui et c'est pour un
coca ou c'est pour intervenir
les deux c'est le retour d'oubli Boyard
en l'honneur de ton retour
je vais donc chanter l'hymne de ta
famille
voilà donc il est heureux oui il nous
avait même me révélé avoir déjà dit les
regarder les deux jeunes qui étaient sur
le plateau même ça les faits énormément
rire un bonheur qui a 21 ans c'est ça
quand vous voyez ces deux jeunes gens
qu'est-ce que c'est si vous dites quoi
différents
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais moi un moment j'étais en galère on
m'a proposé le bail j'ai fait non c'est
pas vrai bah je connaissais un mec il
avait il avait du gros il m'a fait
passer voilà mais
c'est de la merde mais non mais en fait
le truc c'est que j'avais pas le choix
et ça le dérangeait pas de débattre avec
Jean-Michel sur le plateau vous voyez
que j'avais un débat et il représentait
tous les deux les deux la déforestation
au Cameroun il s'y intéressait
je vais vous donner pourquoi je veux
dire pourquoi est-il était content
d'être là puisque je vais vous donner
son cachet dans un instant
oui bah oui bah quand vous savez nous
bah quand on y va on y va oui bon il y a
arrêté donc invité pour parler du bateau
de migrants qui arrivent à Toulon c'est
ça qui nous intéressait malheureusement
il n'en a pas parlé du tout et tout
était très cordial au départ quand il
est arrivé regardez ce que vous n'avez
pas vu à l'antenne regardez on aura avec
nous Louis Boyard député dupesse vous
avez vu on fait même des députés ATP
c'est bon on a eu on a eu deux ou trois
députés
chroniqueur Raquel Garrido Louis Boyard
et je crois qu'il y en a un troisième je
sais plus qui je vais le retrouver donc
vendredi
[Musique]
et donc voilà donc ça va frérot ça me
voilà je vais vous dire les SMS
on va continuer le décryptage vous allez
voir c'est c'est incroyable et puis
surtout je vais vous donner je vais vous
donner toutes les toutes les infos il y
a David Guiraud il nous est ils sont pas
tenues je pense à Swiss mais il nous
regarde apparemment donc on les embrasse
David Guiraud bonjour Géraldine maillet
David qui vient souvent ici avec qui en
plus je m'entends très bien il est là
voilà c'est c'est vous avez déclaré ce
soir est-ce que le vrai racisme c'est
pas de participer à une manifestation
qui se termine par mort aux Juifs avec
des gens de LFI il a pas voulu le mettre
voilà affirmant que lui Boyard y était
de quelle manifestation parlez-vous donc
il vous il vous interpelle alors je sais
pas si vous voyez arrêtez mais en tout
cas il y avait des gens de la LFI qui
était là et comme à chaque fois la LSI
taxe l'émission ou en tout cas de fermer
l'extrême droite et d'être assise je
trouvais que c'était malhonnête
intellectuellement il y a manuel Bompard
aussi de la fille ce soir sur TPMP une
heure de débat pour défendre le soldat
nous là merci au programme mensonge
absence total de contradiction
diffamation où sont les mensonges je ne
vois pas contradictor on les avait
invités ils ont pas voulu venir donc on
a invité des contradicteurs fallait
venir manuellement
alors donc au début tout était cordial
avec Louis Boyard et dès le début du
débat on sentait que Louis était un peu
à côté de la plaque le gars voulaient
que ce soit nous qui trouvions des
solutions regardez
toi bien sûr tu penses que la France a
bien fait bah bien sûr même si jamais ça
a été un peu long mais bien sûr parce
que je vous entends beaucoup dire oui
après qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire bah pour proposer des choses non
mais sachant que propose
voilà donc lui Boyard est député mais il
nous demande à nous de proposer des
choses donc c'est déjà c'est déjà pas
bon signe excusez-moi
c'est compliqué non mais c'est lui qui
prend le salaire aussi donc voilà si on
veut bien proposer des trucs mais qui
nous donne son salaire à l'Assemblée dès
le début du débat donc voilà on voit ça
et très vite Louis a dévié du sujet et a
dit ce pourquoi il était vraiment venu
il voulait se faire le groupe Canal+ et
son patron
on arrête de poser les Français qui sont
pauvres et les immigrés parce que
aujourd'hui en France vous avez cinq
personnes qui possèdent autant que 27
millions de personnes et les cinq
personnes les plus riches les ce sont
les mêmes personnes qui appauvrissent la
France et elles appauvrissent l'Afrique
je vais vous donner l'exemple rien que
de Bolloré le Cameroun voilà alors là
bon on voit on va en venir donc au début
je lui dis je lui demande si c'est où il
est ici je suis plutôt sympa regardez
pas mon genre
excuse-moi mon chéri
donc ici
alors on habitait parce que j'étais un
petit peu voilà tu viens [ __ ]
parce qu'on est obligé de biper
maintenant puisqu'il nous attaque tout
ce qui est qu'est-ce que tu viens [ __ ]
ici tout ça toutes les insultes on les
remplacera par Jean-Marie Bigard
et voilà donc là Louis Boyard Louis
Boyard donc nous dit voilà pourquoi il
est là on voit qu'il commence un peu à
nous chauffer on se dit qu'il est pas là
pour le sujet du bateau j'étais obligé
de rappeler à lui qu'il venait chez nous
qu'il avait été chroniqueur ici regardez
j'ai aucun problème de Bolloré t'as
donné de l'argent puisque tu étais
chroniqueur ici et j'ai aucun problème
alors aucun problème à travailler
attends est-ce que tu es en train de me
dire que j'ai pas le droit de dire
publiquement que Bolloré il a un procès
avec 155
je préfère venir sur la chaîne et dire
que Bolloré a un poussin avec 150
personnes au Camerounais
je devrais être libre
jamais coupé personne on est en direct
mais juste mon chéri c'est nous qui
c'est qui c'est qui qui est chroniqueur
rappelle-moi
de dire à un député qu'il a pas le droit
de dire quelque chose à la télé
Boyard cet été député tu étais
chroniqueurs ici donc j'ai été dire ce
que tu veux ici est-ce qu'on t'a coupé
je te dis juste que ici ici mon chéri
pourquoi pourquoi tu es venu alors
pourquoi tu viens pourquoi tu viens
pourquoi tu as pris de l'argent quand on
t'a pris chroniqueur
quand tu étais ici mais attends
c'est un débat de collégien
après après Louis je pose une question
il dit mais pourquoi vous êtes ici vous
moi c'est mon métier pourquoi pas il
demande pourquoi je suis là et c'est ça
normal
ça serait pas normal je suis député avec
arrogance voilà
ça veut dire il joue un peu à chaque
perché exactement
perte de réalité pour tous les deux il y
a une sorte de père un moment donné on
se rend plus compte ça devient des bas
entre vous deux exactement et on se rend
plus compte qu'à 2 millions de personnes
à 1000000 et demi qui regardent mais on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas ce niveau-là
et pardon j'ai parlé pour moi je vais
même pas moi vous vous êtes un
professionnel des médias chacun est
libre de juger les choux je suis pas
venu ici pour faire de la morale mais ça
m'empêche pas de dire des vérités en
revanche je vais parler pour pardon de
le dire comme tel le métier qui me
concerne le politique quand on est
député
je maîtrise
et quand on vient dans une émission qui
peut toujours partir en circle parce que
c'est le principe de l'émission même
soit on ne vient pas soit on est prêt à
affronter le cirque et quand on est un
député on se tient on est 20 ans quand
on est 45 ans et aujourd'hui je suis un
peu inquiet parce que franchement on
donne pas toujours le goût de la
politique le goût du sérieux de la
politique le goût de enfin comment
voulez-vous
revenir sur la séquence Louis Boyard a
voulu toujours aller plus loin il m'a
accusé de lui avoir demandé des choses
par SMS d'avoir voulu l'influencer et
après la rétropédalier regardez on voit
qu'après rétro [ __ ] ce qui dit là j'ai
dit une connerie il a voulu faire le
malin et il serait trop [ __ ]
dans un instant regardez d'abord
ce que je t'ai déjà appelé moi
je te dis quoi moi je te dis quoi dans
les messages
alors voilà alors bon moi j'ai tous les
messages avec le Boyard il pourra les
mettre s'il veut parce que moi je peux
pas les mettre à l'antenne mais je vais
vous lire voilà mais série pour aller
mettre à l'antenne s'il veut euh voilà
c'était trop bien ce soir ma famille te
remercie pour la chanson c'était qu'on a
droit merci de m'avoir invité à la
prochaine oui Boyard tu étais top bravo
à toi mon Louis tu es génial tu es un
amour il me dit voilà et ensuite le
dernier message qui m'a envoyé
c'est quand il est député à minuit une
tout le monde m'a écrit tout le monde
et lui il m'a écrit coucou Siri je suis
député et ça c'est darka à bientôt on va
faire du lourd
je sais je suis trop content pour toi tu
le mérites
[Applaudissements]
alors le moment où les choses sont
abîmées c'est quand il a rappelé haut et
fort qu'il était élu de la République
sauf que comme je viens de lui montrer
pour moi c'était un copain que j'avais
en face de moi et ben ça part un peu en
cacahuète
même pas compte c'est pas du tout
députés c'est grâce à nous toi
vous vous rendez compte qu'on a pas le
droit de critiquer
va dans un groupe ou tu as le plus de
liberté qui si t'as même pas de liberté
à son bien nationale dès que tu parles
différents
on dit ça va frérot et après il me parle
comme si j'étais si je parlais un député
c'est on parle en pote et on se dit des
choses ou bien tu me dis tout de suite
attends je viens dans l'émission mais je
t'explique maintenant je suis député je
vais te parler et on garde le dimanche
pourquoi je dis ça juste parce que je
vais vous montrer moi ce que vous allez
voir là pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
violent il a l'Assemblée quand je lui ai
dit à l'Assemblée ils t'ont coupé
regardez enfin je veux dire autrement
voilà ma façon regardez ce qu'ils ont
fait
madame la ministre les étudiants ont
faim mais vous ne leur donnez que des
miettes alors que un étudiant sur deux
affirme qu'il ne mange pas à sa fin vous
osez vous vantez d'avoir augmenté les
bourses madame la ministre ma question
est très simple le 24 novembre
soutiendrez-vous notre proposition de
loi instaurant une allocation
d'autonomie pour que chaque jeune puisse
vivre au-dessus du seuil de pauvreté le
24 novembre éradiquez-vous la précarité
[Musique]
voilà donc là ils ont coupé son micro
directement on aurait pu lui couper son
micro parce qu'il dit qu'on ne laisse
pas parler mais je l'ai laissé je lui ai
dit parle j'ai même moi qui l'ai tenu
son micro en moins il a il a cru que
j'allais être arrêté l'antenne bah oui
voilà et c'est vrai que comme comme les
gens me disent voilà c'est vrai que je
l'ai engueuler comme si j'engueuler un
copain un mec avec qui j'ai travaillé en
plus c'est un jeune on a lancé avec les
Grandes Gueules d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
regardez ce que disent de lui les
Grandes Gueules on a l'extrait un
olivier chaud qui Truchot qui dit
regardez
Louis Boyard il se trouve qu'on le
connaît très bien puisque lui a été une
grande gueule et on a quand même pu
mesurer que Louis n'était pas l'homme le
plus loyal du monde puisqu'il va
raconter les choses il devait faire la
saison passée c'était l'année dernière
et puis le jour de la conférence de
presse on annonçait les nouvelles
grandes gueules il nous appelle en
disant ben je vais chez Hanouna je vous
plante les gars donc c'est vrai que en
terme de loyauté
c'est pas quand même le mieux placé et
c'est vrai qu'hier bon il vient sur le
plateau de C8 il veut critiquer Bolloré
il ne l'a pas fait lorsque
qui était payé comme chroniqueur du même
Cyril Hanouna donc là il y a
effectivement une façon de cracher dans
la soupe qui est quand même pas terrible
merci
Olivier qui rappelle les choses et
Olivier je te le dis tu aurais mieux
fait de le garder franchement je te dis
si tu veux je peux tu peux le reprendre
il y a pas de problème Louis Boyard a
ensuite voulu se lâcher la faire Lola le
racisme le gars tout mélanger et c'est
surtout la là il a dit des choses très
très grave voilà et c'est ça qui a fait
que ça s'est revenu mais parce que Louis
Boyard ne peut pas dire ça d'ailleurs
sachez-le on va poursuivre en justice ou
ibonia non seulement pour ce qu'il a dit
ce qu'on l'avait il dit qu'ils ont là
incité à dire des choses dans l'émission
que j'avais su faire des choses donc ils
sortent les SMS et on va l'attaquer pour
ça et on va l'attaquer également pour ce
qu'il a dit là regarde
tu prenais ton cachet tu faisais le
malin pourquoi tu prends ton cachet tous
les jours l'actualité
alors vous voyez je suis plus que calme
jusqu'à présent et quand il nous reste
le raciste dire qu'on fait monter le
racisme on invitera toujours tout le
monde ici fou et ça je vous le dis et
c'est des gens comme Louis Boyard qui
font monter le racisme ils sont montés
sur tout le communautarisme ils sont
montés les qui montent les uns contre
les autres ce sont des comportements
comme celui-là nous on est ouais on est
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord sur plein
de trucs avec Julien avec Carl
avec toutes les personnes qui sont ici
je vous dis voilà mine de rien avec les
LR aussi on s'est pris la tête et puis
c'est vrai mais on discute on parle on
dit voilà on n'est pas d'accord sur ça
comme on peut faire et on essaie de
trouver des solutions je vous dis eux
ils votent mon avis que Louis Boyard et
je mets pas toute la LSF dedans puisque
voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est à part
c'est lui qui est venu en premier ici
donc euh voilà c'est lui le premier qui
est venu en émission donc ça je peux pas
lui jeter la pierre mais eux pour lui
Boyard il faudrait qu'on habite que des
gens de la fille avec ses idéologies et
son idée allez si possible que lui ça
c'est ça c'est un support et quand il
nous traitent à nous quand il nous dit
de faire monter la racine ou de faire le
boss sur Zemmour ou un il faut qu'il
comprenne un truc j'allais le traiter
encore heureusement vous avez vu voilà
je peux avoir de proposer
non mais quand on continue
on traite des sujets qui font
l'actualité malheureusement pour lui
Éric Zemmour en l'an dernier il a fait
parler lui pendant des semaines et des
semaines donc forcément à la fin
exactement on parlait d'Éric Zemmour si
Valérie Pécresse avait fait parler
d'elle on aurait parlé de Valérie
Pécresse tous les jours un moment Marine
Le Pen on a parlé énormément d'elle
parce que
Emmanuel Macron quand il est il est venu
ou pas on a parlé lui donc voilà mais
quand on vient chez vous on sait où on
met les pieds ah oui quand on vient chez
vous on sait on met les pieds et on sait
qu'on est capable de tout dire vous
voyez quand je revois cette
distance et je vais l'ajuster après je
pense que le Boyard il s'est cru dans
l'assemblée mais nous à l'Assemblée on a
ça tous les jours on a ça tous les jours
et il faut supporter ça tous les jours
et je peux vous dire que très
régulièrement c'est insupportable pour
autant je pense que vous n'étiez plus
dans votre rôle quand la fête pour moi
vous avez été débordé par vos états
d'âme parce qu'en face de vous vous êtes
quelqu'un que vous aimez vous l'avez dit
ça sauf que là on vous demande pas
d'être le frérot le pote vous êtes là
vous êtes l'animateur le présentateur et
à ce titre là vous devez vous comporter
comme ça et moi je sais qu'ici on peut
tout dire alors comme Eduardo a sorti
une petite formule tout à l'heure de
Jean-Paul sat juste vous dire quelque
chose qui pourrait vous aller très bien
de Voltaire je ne suis pas d'accord avec
tout ce que vous vous dites mais je me
battrai jusqu'à la mort pour que vous
ayez les droits de le dire c'est ce que
vous faites systématiquement un bémol
près l'insultez pas Cyril un insultez
pas
c'est comme moi je veux dire je prends
comme exemple c'est un peu comme le
coupable de Zidane Zidane voilà le coup
de boule de Zidane aussi il a pété un
câble il dit je le regrette pas mais
j'en suis pas fier alors comme je peux
vous dire un truc je peux vous dire que
les autres copains de l'équipe de France
lui en veulent toujours et ben aussi
football moi j'en ai assez avec moi
alors on va revenir on va revenir juste
l'embrouille à continuer on était
clairement pas face à un mec qui voulait
parler des migrants justement je trouve
que ça dessert son combat ce qu'il a
fait là ça dessert son combat c'est bête
parce que voilà s'il en avait un sale
dessert il avait une seule obsession
alors Monsieur Vincent Bolloré voilà qui
est actionné à quoi que ce soit
l'obsession c'est lui-même mais regardez
regardez c'est incroyable
je vais vous donner l'exemple rien que
de Bolloré
il a un problème
il a un procès avec 150
personnes au Cameroun il a un processus
je te dis je te dis je sais même pas
donc on a pas le droit mais tu sais quoi
vous
vous rendez créer de la misère politique
on n'a pas le droit de cliquer Bolloré
bolo
c'est ton débattant qu'on débat et non
pas en méprisant je voudrais dire à
Louis Boyard ça c'est un truc que je
voulais dire que je pensais tout le
weekend et pour revenir à Vincent
Boulouris sachez que ce n'est même pas
Vincent voler qui m'a fait venir dans le
groupe Canal+ je suis venu avant Vincent
Bolloré c'est vrai je suis venu avant
c'est Rodolphe belle-mère l'ancien
patron de canal qui a repris les chaînes
Direct 8
qui m'a fait venir c'est lui qui m'a
fait venir et Vincent Bolloré est arrivé
après et devenu actionner le groupe mais
sachez une chose et je le dis et
Jean-Marie me connaît c'est pour lui
soit Gad Elmaleh que ce soit Jean-Marie
pas son boulot il est pas mon patron
Vincent Bolloré et je le redis ce soir
c'est un ami de 20 ans un ami de 20 ans
un ami qui m'a toujours soutenu qui
était le seul à m'appeler quand j'avais
200 euros par mois et par semaine
parfois ou par semaine ou par mois ça
dépendait des mois grâce à ma mère et
c'était le seul qui prenait de mes
nouvelles le seul qui était toujours là
pour moi et qui me disait comment ça va
qu'est-ce qui se passe comment tu vas et
confiance en toi ça va marcher etc et un
ami de 20 ans je le défendrai toujours
sachez-le et mes amis je les défendrai
toujours et je serai toujours que ce
soit Jean-Marie que ce soit Gad Elmaleh
que ce soit Vincent Bolloré que ce soit
les chroniqueurs ici soit Géraldine
voilà Valérie je les défendrai toujours
et ça je vous le dis moi c'est vrai que
je suis sanguin c'est vrai que je peux
dire des choses c'est vrai que voilà je
peux parfois déraper mais sachez que je
suis vrai et pour moi
le plus gros reproche que je peux faire
à Louis Boyard jeudi c'est qui vous a
berné que lui il a été faux moi j'étais
vrai lui était fou ce qu'il avait tout
pré médité et Louis Boyard était venu
dans un seul but faire du buzz quitter
le plateau et s'attaquer à TPMP
s'attaquer au groupe et s'attaquer à
notre actionnaire en s'attaquant à moi
c'est ce qu'il a fait je vous le dis
alors moi bien sûr je lis je regrette
les propos injurieux mais je vous le dis
et c'est bête que je vais dire dans une
guerre sont toujours les Gentils qui
gagnent à la fin et pour moi oui Boyard
et le méchant il avait tout pré médité
chez Boyard a eu ce qu'il a voulu il a
fait son buzz et là il est fille je
pense ils sont plus intelligents que lui
et je pense qu'ils vont venir sur le
plateau Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est ce
qu'on a fait pour lui ainsi craquer le
Garrido et je pense qu'ils vont venir
Louis Bogard
un moment nature et Daniel lui parle de
son salaire chez nous il lui dit de
rembourser bah son salaire il est simple
je veux dire qu'on m'a touché Louis
Boyard s'il veut le reverser en tout
Louis Boyard a touché plus de 6000 euros
est-ce que vous l'avez ici les Chéries
oui Boyard voilà il était payé voilà
tout ça voilà il a touché
6794 euros chez nous voilà donc si il
veut les reverser
ma Daniel c'est plus qu'un député voilà
donc c'est vrai que voilà Louis Boyard
pour moi je voulais faire député je vais
pas le faire
[Rires]
nous a menti à tous jeudi en direct il
avait il nous a trahi il a trahi son ami
avec qui disait on va faire des darka
quand je fais des députés et ça c'est
bien plus grave parce que des problèmes
on en aura dans l'émission de la
traversée plein de crise mais on a
traversera encore et l'important c'est
que c'était les spectateurs jouaient bon
merci d'être toujours là de nous
regarder et de savoir qui vous regardez
ce que vous regardez et vous connaissez
notre sincérité dans l'émission ça on ne
pourra jamais nous l'enlever notre
sincérité et Louis Boyard est un garçon
qui n'est pas sincère et pour moi ça
c'est la pire des choses c'est un
menteur
et je vous dis Isa il sait jouer de vous
c'est jouer le public ne s'est pas
trompé d'ailleurs puisqu'il l'a eu et
lui a demandé de sortir et il était
extrêmement violent sur le plateau et
Louis Boyard n'en sortira pas grandit de
cette affaire et sachez que nous aussi
on va prendre des mesures et on va
attaquer pour ce qu'il a pu dire
diffamation et toute la diffamation
qu'il a eu à notre égard